alright okay I'm Winston Cheng and I'm
going to be talking about the r6 class
system so first off I want to I one of
my colleagues pointed me to this webpage
this is at our documentation org run by
a data camp and it lists the most
downloaded packages and I didn't I
didn't realize this but apparently r6 is
the most downloaded package it's for
object oriented programming and so that
was a little surprising to me but when I
thought about it it made sense because
there's a lot of very popular packages
that use r6 like deep fire for example
one thing it did sound very surprising
though is that in this column here
apparently is the most popular directly
downloaded package which means that a
lot of people are doing install about
packages r6
so either people are very very into
object oriented programming and are or
there's some problem with the data and I
see okay so they're so working in this
that data can so so this is not true
sadly as I suspected all right so some
doesn't give you some numbers here are 6
by the numbers it's been out on cran for
three years it's only 588 lines of code
there's about 17 hundred lines of tests
so it's well tested package apparently
it's the number one package on cran for
at least for indirect downloads I hope
that's true and I've given 0 talks about
it until today so I'm very excited
that's my first talk about our 6 even
though it's been out for a while and is
widely used alright I'm going to start
off with talking about ours
built in object-oriented programming
systems there's a classification that
John Chambers use is in this book
extending our functional object-oriented
programming systems and encapsulated
object-oriented programming systems so
for the functional object oriented
programming that's exemplified by the s3
and s4 systems in R and for encapsulated
object oriented programming that's
that's exemplified by reference classes
and our these are the ones that are
built into art so the differences
between them include this for for
functional object oriented programming
the objects contain data but class
methods that operate on on those objects
they're separate the methods themselves
are separate from the objects and the
objects are not mutable so whenever you
have a function that operates on an
object and if it modifies the object it
what actually happens is you get a copy
of the object and then you can you can
choose to store that cup modified copy
or or not for encapsulated
object-oriented programming the objects
contain both the data and the methods
the objects are immutable they can
change when you call a method or if you
if you modify things in it and it's also
known as classical object-oriented
programming so this is the type of of
thing system you'd see with like Java
C++ or Python this is you know much more
common in the wider core gaming world
okay so for using functional object
oriented programming you might do
something like if you've got your object
X you call a summary of X and there
might be a method for your particular
class that gives you a summary if you
want to modify X you call some function
modified here modify X and that doesn't
like as I said that doesn't modify X in
place it returns a new object which you
would have to save back in X for now for
encapsulated object-oriented programming
the methods are part of the objects too
and dollar sign is the subset operator
so you'd say X dollar summary you might
have a method that modifies object X
dollar modify that could change in place
you don't have to save that back in X
and if you pass X to a function like I
have this object called trim you know it
may change X or it might not change X so
from the outside you can't you can't
tell and because of this because of this
it can be easier to reason about
functional object-oriented programming
where every time you want to modify an
object you there's you always have an
assignment operator
whereas with encapsulated you don't know
what if it's going to change but but
encapsulated object or engine
programming is the
useful for representing data that
evolves over time and some real-world
examples of this are where our sixes use
our shiny so they're shiny session is
represented with an r6 object it
represents the state of the application
of the user interacts with it in deep
fire our six objects are used to
represent database connections and in
this packet and relatively new package
package called process X by gobbler is
already at our six objects are used to
represent system processes so in this
case these are all sort of things that
have connections to things that are
outside of our and that's where this is
one very common use case for
encapsulated object or origin
programming
okay so here's a basic r6 class this is
how you define a class you'd call
function r6 class you give it a label in
this case it's a accumulator there a
name and and there's and then here I'd
say there's a list of these public these
public properties one of them is the
some accumulator I just want to add
values to it to a total sum so the stone
starts off at zero and then there's a
method called add and this is a function
that takes a value X and it takes self
dollar some adds X and then it assigns
it best to self Dell or some and then
this method returns self it returns the
accumulator object so that you can chain
it together we'll see this below okay so
now in order to so that defines the
class to instantiate the class to create
an object of that class you'd say
accumulator dollar new and save that in
X and now I can say X dollar add 4 or X
dollar add 10 and then add 10 because
this returns this first add 10 returns
that accumulator object and so I can
keep using the dollar sign and you know
calling this add method and at the end I
can access the Sun just by using Excel
or some so that's that's the very basics
of creating an r6
class now for an example it's a little
bit more useful here's an example of a
stack so this is we use in SHINee we use
stacks or to keep track of various
things keep track of various bits of
state and I won't go into the details of
this code but the important things are
that there's some public methods here
push you push things on the stack top
you take the top item off the stack and
size is a method that tells you how many
items are in the stack and now the new
thing here is that there's also some
private stuff so there's a this is a
list it contains one thing the items
items in the stack which is also what
right begins with an empty list and
they're not accessible from outside and
from inside the class you can use
private dollar items to access that
value so I can modify it or read it
using private dollar items so this list
keeps this encapsulated all you get to
see are the functions from the outside
all right I'm going to use it you'd say
SS stack dollar new s dollar push one
push five to ten push text and then if
you pop them off it'll take them off in
reverse order okay so that's that's a
slightly more useful example of a class
and if you were to do this with
functional programming you might have a
function stack that creates a stack
object and you save it in s and then
when you want to add things to you'd
have to say push F comma one and that
doesn't modify Epps in place you have to
save that back in s and every time you
push things you'd have to do that and
when you if you want to remove things
from the stack if you want to get the
top item and then shorter then never
remove it from the stack first you'd
call a function that takes that type ID
a top item off let's say last of s save
that x1 and then you call the remove
last of F to modify US itself and then
you'd have to save that back in s so
there's two steps here well with using
our six the method it both modifies s
and then it returns the value
that you're interested in okay so
another handy feature of our six classes
are initializer methods so in the stack
class that it just starts off empty the
one that I showed you but you can add a
special method called initialize and in
this one it's a function that takes dot
dot dot arguments and it just assigned
those elements as the beginning the
starting state of the stack so if I say
stack dollar new I'd say Jack dollar new
five six seven and then the stack starts
with those items in the stack
it also supports inheritance so if you
want to create a subclass I've got my
base class stack I've got and I create
this fancier stack class called stack
two with some extra features I'd say our
six class inherit equals stack and then
there's an initialize method and I can
override it so I can add methods and I
can override methods so I can add a push
method which overrides the base classes
push method and this one it takes again
a variable list of arguments and for
each it loops over them and it called
the super classes push method and just
pushes each one on to the stack all
right so you can you can you can use
super to access methods from the
superclass and one nice thing again is
that it's the API is encapsulate the
data so all you get to see from outside
going back to the original stack class
it's just these methods so if you want
to refactor it and make it more
performant make it more efficient you
just have to make sure those methods
continue to work properly be if you
change the internal data structure you
don't have to worry that somebody has
written code that uses that internal
data structure and will break when you
change it all right now once you use our
six when you need object-- with
reference semantics that's often again
often when you're representing external
resources that's a common case when you
want to encapsulate the data and just
expose a particular interface to your
data
and also when you don't want to pollute
the your working environment when it's a
whole bunch of methods those methods
instead of becoming just sort of
floating out there they're part of your
objects so they're they're contained in
there so Reverend classes existed before
our six did so so a comparison between
them so our six some of the advantages
of our sticks are that it's simple and
lightweight as I said it's only 580
lines of code
it supports private properties or as
reference classes with reference classes
everything is public
there's robust inheritance you can have
inheritance across packages about any
compromises and that can be a bit of a
problem for reference classes and also
the generators and our six objects are
fully encapsulated so they don't act
once you've created them they don't call
any functions from the r6 package which
means that you can save them out and
then load them in another our session
with which has say a different version
of r6 or doesn't even have our six
installed at all and they will continue
to function so that can avoid a class of
sort of hard to diagnose bugs because of
that for reference classes it's built
into R which is a big thing so there's
built-in support everywhere it's built
using s4 and the methods package and
also the fields can be can have types in
reference classes so those comparison
obviously I'm biased I'm sure somebody
here will have something to say about
this and for more information you can
see the living EPS that I think that's a
pretty good introduction if you go to
the cran package page or you can just
run the vignette function and I could
let's see alright so how our SiC is
implemented so our six objects are just
environments with a particular structure
it's it's pretty simple once you
understand it so normally when when
you're running our code you have your
object here this is just the value 10
you have a binding to that object this
is a name X it never refers to this
object here value 10 that binding lives
in an environment you're probably
familiar usually working in the global
if you're working at our the console on
environments have parents so that's what
this arrow represents here that
relationship then if you if it doesn't
find a name a binding here it'll search
in the parent environment and it will
keep going until it hits the bottom
there's also function objects and they
have a special a special thing which is
they have this this area here represents
the enclosing environment so that's sort
of in some sense the environment where
the function runs it'll search for
things in this enclosing environment
alright so this is the basic way that
the objects in bindings environments
work now for our six and our six object
consists of usually two or maybe three
objects or three two or three
environments I should say so one is a
sort of public this is the public facing
environments I call it here the public
binding environment it has like X and
this is a different function name from
before how X Y and this points to a
function and this functions in closing
environment is not it's not this public
binding environment it's a special
enclosing environment which contains
just the bindings itself and so self
refers back to this public binding
environment so if you want to access X
you'd say self dollar X you can't just
say you can't just access X from that
function directly and this enclosing
environment the parent would if you're
in a package it would typically be the
package namespace so it could call all
the these functions can call all the
internal functions from that package and
it looks like I'm out of time so I will
I'll sort of I'll just go back to the
original slide but this is this is the
basics of all our six isn't it there's
two separate environments all right so I
will go back to this and I guess I can
take some questions
[Applause]
clang pencil questions yeah so as you
mentioned the reference classes seem
very similar to classes implemented in
C++ Java Python I was wondering if you
just do a quick compare can't rest if
there's things you can do here that
can't be done there or vice versa just
boy that's you know I am NOT expert
enough in those languages to really say
okay I'm sorry over here right off
I think the functions or the methods or
hidden kind of behind at our sixth class
what's the best way to troubleshoot or
profile a function when when we're using
or six for troubleshooting you can you
can call debug on not on the class but
you have to call debug on an instance
like you know s dollar push or something
you call debug on that and then we run
it you could step through it or you can
put a browser statement in it that's
what I do a lot or you can you can use
profetas with the profiling package for
for profiling and it should show up in a
way that's somewhat easy to understand
using process that's
years ago as fall was considerably
slower than is-3 I don't know if that's
the case anymore but do you have any
condiment on on speed of 1/6 compared
with with uh yeah so when I like first
when I created r6 there's there's
actually one of the vignettes has
performance comparisons with reference
classes and reference classes are built
on s4 and it's considered weak I mean
doing simple operations but just
accessing a field can be or modifying a
field can be at an order of five or ten
times faster because there's type
checking that happens with reference
classes the vignette it's automatically
built every time I submit it to cran so
there's benchmarks on there which I
haven't looked at recently but I assume
that there's still quite a bit of
performance advantage
so can you defeat the privacy using like
the triple colon operator and things
like that there is yeah there's a it's
actually not that hard it it used to be
much harder but now you can do like X
dollar and then there's a special
variable and they're called dot
underscore underscore and close and if
you have your tab auto-completion it
should just come up and then you do that
that's in closing environment so from
there you can just private you see if I
can yeah that that it refers to this
thing and you can access private from
there is a private property of the class
does that is that still private for the
subclause sorghum is this private for
the subclass of that class or the
subclass can access it can access
certain classes just fine I'm bought
compilation does that all work fine with
r6 oh I believe that when you build a
package with r6 the bike compilation
does not work so I'm not an expert on
that stuff I believe if you use like the
the just-in-time compiler it will
probably compile it as it goes but it
will not as far as I know compile it for
the class as a whole it will probably
compile each instance each method
instance
okay they appear to be no questions
anymore and I'd like to thank old
speakers again
[Applause]